[Musique]
montserra Renaldo je suis né en Bretagne
je suis à la Réunion depuis 25 ans donc
je suis professeur je travaille en
classe relais avec des jeunes qui sont
un peu des des jeunes rebelles et depuis
25 ans bon ben on a je mène un combat
avec des amis avec des auteurs avec des
écrivains avec des tas de gens qui
veulent bien s'engager disons pour pour
la
société c'est quelqu'un qui a du cœur
qui a qui a l'écoute mais il apporte
beaucoup de choses par rapport que
métait un petit peu m'avait pas
confiance du tout en moi en 2008 on a
créé l'association Graine couleur
écriture sociale c'était au départ une
association qui avait comme rôle de de
donner la parole à ceux qui ne l'
prennent pas ceux qui pour pour qui
c'est un peu confus timide rentrer
inhibé et de faire que bon les mauvaises
scolaires
ressortent au fur et à mesure des années
on s'est rendu compte queil fallait
qu'on aide peut-être un peu mieux que ça
qu'il fallait qu'on crée un projet qu'on
amène toutes ces personnes à à entrer
dans une dynamique plus plus positive
plus constructive par rapport à la
société d'aujourd'hui et puis par
rapport à leur
avenir et donc on est passé au chantier
d'assertion donc
on se retrouve on se trouve là
aujourd'hui un jardin un jardin
solidaire un jardin qui permet aux
personnes donc d'avoir un nouveau
rapport avec la
[Rires]
[Musique]
vie